Today we will discuss the concepts of disclosure and misrepresentation by
examining one of my favorite contract cases.
You might have noticed that most of the cases we've been learning about are
decided by state courts.
Since contracts are usually governed by state law laid law.
The Oregon which was decided by the United States supreme court in 1817 is an
exception.
The case has been recognized by legal scholars as a foundational case in the
history of us contract law and it's been cited numerous times and law review
articles,
appellate briefs and other cases.
Before we review the case itself,
you might have noticed that the case reading was slightly unusual.
The first few paragraphs are actually summaries of the lawyers arguments and the
court's opinion appeared only at the very end.
Ingersoll was the lawyer for Laidlaw key was the lawyer for the defendant,
Oregon.
The decision at the end of the case was written by none other than chief justice
John Marshall who delivered it on behalf of unanimous court.
If you've taken constitutional law,
you'll remember chief justice Marshall as the author of Marbury versus Madison.
Another unusual aside.
Hector,
Oregon's lawyer at the Supreme Court was Francis Scott Key,
if that name sounds familiar,
it's because Francis Scott Key composed our national anthem in the painting you
see on the side key beholds the American flag is still flying over Fort Mchenry
at dawn on September 14th,
1814 the events which inspired him to write the Star spangled banner events
surrounding the war of 1812 Mr Madison's war not only inspired key to pin oh,
say,
can you see it gave rise to one of the greatest cases in contract law.
The plaintiff appellee and buyer Oregon entered into a deal to buy 111 hogs.
Heads of tobacco from the defendant appellant seller laid law for $7,545.
This was a large purchase.
111 hogsheads is about 111,000 pounds of tobacco.
The purchase was made around the time that news broke of the peace treaty of
Ghent,
which ended the war of 1812.
During the war.
The price of tobacco was very low because of the British naval embargo around,
uh,
the city of New Orleans.
Because of the war,
literally tons of tobacco.
We're going unsold,
warehoused on the docks of New Orleans.
Once the war was over and the embargo lifted,
this tobacco would be worth a lot more money.
Defendant laid law initially delivered tobacco to the plaintiff,
but later retook the hogs heads by force.
The defendant alleged plaintiff had heard from the British fleet the news about
the signing of the peace treaty before this news was made public and was
consequently able to buy at an artificially depressed embargo price.
When the defendant asked if there was any news which was calculated to enhance
the price or value of the article about to be purchase,
the plaintiff apparently remained silent when the signing of the treaty was
announced to the public.
The value of tobacco increased from 30 to 50%.
The plaintiff,
the buyer,
Oregon filed suit for breach of contract to regain the tobacco or to be awarded
damages.
The lower court found for the plaintiff,
the instant court,
the US Supreme Court reversed and remanded.
The main issue in this case was whether plaintiff's non responsiveness to the
defendant's question constitutes fraud.
In this case,
the plaintiff concealed information about the signing of the peace treaty of
Ghent that affected the price of tobacco at which they would have contracted
justice.
Marshall held that no.
The suppression of information in this case did not constitute fraud.
There's no duty in arm's lengths transactions to disclose information.
However,
Justice Marshall also held quote,
each party must take care not to say or do anything tending to impose upon the
other.
So what was the holding of laid lobby Oregon?
Which party won this case?
There's actually a complicated answer.
On the one hand,
Marshall clearly states the rule that the buyer quote was not bound to
communicate unquote the news that the war had ended.
On the other hand,
Marshall also holds that quote,
whether any imposition was practiced by the vendee upon the Venn door ought to
have been submitted to the jury.
He remands the case on that basis.
If the,
if the buyer was under no duty to disclose what other imposition might there
have been?
Yeah,
well the fact that the seller asked a question and got no answer played
important role in the decision.
If the question was asked,
do you know of any news and and the buyer answers?
No.
That would clearly be fraud.
The buyer silence in this situation might be though interpreted as a yes.
If you were a seller and ask that question and the buyer was silent or
responded,
how about those mets?
You might worry that the buyer had something to hide,
but sometimes non-responsiveness throws the questioner off track.
That's why politicians are nonresponsive to so many questions.
The court said that the buyer's silence in some cases might tend to impose upon
other people.
This is probably why the case was remanded,
so there are two main holdings of the case.
First,
there is no duty to disclose information in arms length transactions,
but second and implicit misrepresentation by silence in the face of a question
is possibly actionable.
Let's talk for a moment about the duty of disclosure.
The first holding in Laidlaw that the buyer did not have a general duty to
disclose that the war had ended was quite influential in the development of US
law.
It was not until the second half of the 20th century that US courts began
recognizing a duty to disclose in our blanks transactions often on the heels of
legislative disclosure requirements.
Thus,
the ninth circuit could write as late as 1967 quote businessmen dealing at arm's
length or rarely under a duty to speak.
Then quote today,
courts are more willing to recognize a duty to disclose and arm length
transactions.
Section one 61 of the restatement states the conditions where a person's
nondisclosure of a fact can be treated as the fact not existing at all.
One of the conditions is where disclosure of the fact would correct a mistake of
the other party as to a basic assumption of the contract.
This clearly has implications for the Laidlaw case.
However,
even under Laidlaw,
it's possible to create a duty of disclosure.
Laidlaw teaches that by asking the question,
one party can create for the other party a duty to disclose.
Alternatively a party might demand and explicit representation from the other
that she has no material nonpublic information concerning the contract.
Section one 61 B of the restatement also suggests that a party can created of
disclosure by making a representation herself.
For example,
imagine that the seller had said,
I represent to you buyer that I laid law have no reason to think that the price
of tobacco is about to rise and my belief is a basic assumption under which I am
entering into this contract.
Under section one 61 the buyer might have a duty to disclose to correct the
buyer's mistake as to this basic assumption
in a later class,
we will learn more about how the duty of disclosure is treated by a modern court
in Hill v Jones.
If courts can hear implicit representations in response to a question or in
response to representations,
why couldn't courts go further and here are default or implicit representations
as a part of all promising?
Imagine the law created a default representation by every contractor which said,
quote,
I have no private information suggesting that you shouldn't want to contract
with me.
Under these terms unquote this default implicit representation,
it would merely be a default and it could be avoided by a contractor revealing
that they had undisclosed information or disclosing the private information
itself.
Wouldn't that make our contracting world better?
Why make a worried sellers ask questions or make their own representations?
Well,
one reason we might not want that kind of a default disclosure requirement is
because we don't want to discourage people like Oregon from going out and
discovering the value of things.
Anthony Kronman pointed out that the law should distinguish between casually
acquired information and information that is deliberately acquired through the
active effort of an individual.
If the law requires contractors to reveal private information,
especially about the value of goods,
the disclosure duty might very well blunt the incentive for individuals to go
out and find the value of things.
Value Discovery effort provides benefits for society.
Stock market prices might be a lot less accurate under such a disclosure
default.
So it might make sense to require the other side to do something more,
uh,
in effect,
to,
uh,
bargain for this private information.
To summarize,
laid law introduced the idea that there's no duty to disclose in arm lengths
negotiations.
This idea was incredibly influential in American contract legal history.
It was only until recently that courts have imposed a duty of disclosure in
certain circumstances.
In addition,
laid law also introduced the idea that silence in the face of a question could
constitute an actual actionable implicit misrepresentation.
Finally,
we've learned that by making a representation you might be able to create a
disclosure duty on the other side to correct your mistake.
We will later on examined the duty of disclosure and the concept of
misrepresentation in much greater detail in the next few lessons.